hey guys I'm Jess I'm Dan and right here
to talk to you about the video gaming
these things that happened this Monday
all the weekend we not much happened
today so I'm gonna tell you a few things
first up a week or so ago we told you
guys that player and owns battlegrounds
was up there as the second most
concurrently played game on the same
also at the time we said this
oh wait could surpass dota 2 but here we
are a few days ago on September 16th the
title passed 1.3 4 million users
officially beating the 1.29 million
records set by dota 2 in March of 2016
these figures come from Steam charts so
they may not be perfectly accurate but
one thing is for certain a lot of you
guys are playing the island sized
hide-and-seek with guns game
battlegrounds is currently still in
development and is available on Steam
early access for 30 bucks
well dota 2 is a free to play first
party title from valve that is heavily
promoted so yeah good job battlegrounds
you may have heard this one over the
weekend but it seemed like kind of PSA
important thing to know gearbox is a
hero shoot across the MOBA battleborn
will no longer be supported with updates
father born creative director Randy
Vaughn L posted on the game's forums as
of this week there will be no more
battle plans and there's currently no
plant content after the full update the
game servers will remain up but the
upcoming update that will feature new
Borderlands themed skin updated title
art and new fish abuse and taunts will
be the last update final went on to say
that he'll be transitioning to an
unannounced gearbox game and said it's
been a long labor of love with many of
my good friends at gearbox and I'm proud
to have shared that journey with you our
community your spirit and loyalty have
been a constant inspiration to the team
at gearbox let us know what you think of
this one and what you think the
unannounced game gearbox is working on
could be finally due to an era fortnight
enabled cross play between ps4 and Xbox
one over the weekend while playing the
game over the weekend
reddit user and ps4 fortnight play a
pre-season can we just I'm just going to
just interrupt this story for a second
think about the poor people doing this
this job who have to say your username
in real life it's really difficult to
say pyaari underscore - cas io n -
underscore just write precision just
right procedures notice the fellow
player with the space in their name
spaces are not allowed in PSN IDs but
are in xbox live gamertag z'
after some speculation that it was a PC
player further investigation by gamers
on Reddit and NeoGAF found at the space
have a user name didn't exist in the
games
EPIK launcher on pc but did on xbox live
more evidence was later shared including
one person claiming to be playing with
their kid across the two consoles
fortnight's developer epic games seemed
to confirm this as when reached for
comment by GameSpot replied we have a
configuration issue and it has now been
corrected Microsoft has recently voiced
their support for cross play leaving
Sony to come to the table no word on if
this one was a simple technical hitch or
a new feature set to go live soon but as
soon as we know illness that's
everything we have here today make sure
your subscribe so you can see us every
day of the working week with all the
gaming news you'll ever need and we're
tomorrow so we'll see you know because
sucker-punches new game is gonna be
cross play with xbox live copies of
battlefield how will that help
Sony sucker punch is going to announce
it this year it's gonna be announced
alright man